depuis son enfant stéphane est atteint
de la maladie de charcot marie
complètement autonome il vivait seul
dans son appartement à maurepas avant de
faire la rencontre d'isabelle ils se
sont trouvés il y a dix ans via facebook
grâce à la page 1 10 sport je regardais
les gens qui aimait et j'ai vu son nom
jeckyll katina commence à parler on a
sympathisé elle est venue à un week-end
puis ensuite de weekend trois week-ends
le père et le grand frère d'isabelle
étant tous les deux des personnes en
fauteuil roulant l'handicap ne lui a
jamais fait peur
comme j'ai plusieurs personnes
handicapées dans la famille lors du tome
me freiner quand j'ai montré une photo
de stéphane amiot papa il a d'ailleurs
il en fauteuil bien il est comme moi
donc il n'a toutefois accepté malgré le
handicap de stéphane la répartition des
tâches ménagères est bien établie chacun
sait ce qu'il doit faire en général
c'est elle qui cuisine oui c'est moi qui
fais la vaisselle sur moi j'aime ça je
fais souvent le ménage parce que j'aime
ça aussi puis ça m'occupe qui ça fait du
physique aussi c'est un peu de sport qui
ça tombe bien j'aime pas faire ça parce
que je peux pas faire là le fait et puis
en général je me débrouille assez bien
isabelle est remplaçante à la mairie de
maurepas pour aider les personnes âgées
stéphane lui vit de son allocation
handicapé les deux avouent avoir déjà
penser au mariage et à fonder une
famille mais financièrement ce serait
trop compliqué ça c'est difficile parce
que j'ai que l'âge en l'allocation
handicapé j'ai une maladie héréditaire
qui risquent de transmettre qui risquent
de se transmettre donc si on a un enfant
qui à ma maladie ça veut dire des soins
derrière
je sais pense vitalisation néanmoins ans
entre tout ça c'est des frais eux elle l
est pas pour l'instant n'est pas appelée
par la mairie donc en l'instant ce sera
ses shows d'avoir un enfant en tout cas
les dés sont unanimes amour et handicap
sont compatibles c'est pas parce qu'on
est handicapé qu'on n'a pas droit à
l'amour
rien du tout quand deux êtres ce n ya
rien il n'y a pas d'interdît à rien bon
voilà faut pas faire en fonction de ce
que les gens pensent elle est handicapée
dont l'oise y trouve quelqu'un d'autre
ou il a un handicap ita rien au foot
avec tout ça c'est des conneries il
était handicapé ita pas droit à ce à
quoi la